hey you're
listening to the dollop on the all
things
comedy network well this is a bilingual
american history podcast where each week
i read a story in two languages to my
friend from american history
gareth reynolds who has no idea what the
topic is going to be about
um how are you
what's this happening how was your we
don't do it how was your airplanes
every one of them was really good your
airplanes were good
not a problem in one flight
now if you if you could fly and
have your luggage lost and then come
back next to a baby
would is that good you like
that's why i do it i do it for the
travel
i do it to i have open seating in
southwest i feel like i've got a perfect
plot of land
only to have someone built it yeah i'm
gonna have i'm gonna teach a child about
the uh differences between earth's
pressure and disguise pressure today
that's nice i'm gonna see what the baby
reacts like when i'm squishing its head
with air pressure here's the thing about
babies
they get it they get it because they
understand what's happening dave
like i've been taught they got places to
go
[Laughter]
business babies mm-hmm oh wait oh god
what are your awkwardness
let me
aaron for that is beyond me because he
made me unplugging never know
you unplugged it because it was making a
noise and you didn't even play it
[ __ ]
and called it quote his jam pad jim
i'm the [ __ ] hippo guy dave okay my
name is gary
my name's gary wait is it for fun and
this is not gonna become the tickling
podcast okay
this is like adam and a five-part
confession
now you both present sick
arguments no sleep down hippo
action park hi gabby no nicely done my
friends
you can go to our website dogpodcast.com
and we have
shows coming up in
utah salt lake city we're going to
colorado denver we're going to arizona
in the city of phoenix and we're doing
las vegas so you get tickets for those
right now
later on we'll be in the year we'll be
in san francisco
sacramento and san diego tickets are
also on sale for those and then we're
doing a tour of australia all the usual
cities plus uh new zealand
tickets are on sale for those uh get
your [ __ ] together yeah
[ __ ] together stay inside so we can come
and play uh
and go to dallappodcast.com like dave
said for all the ticketing information
i will be uh i gareth reynolds will be
thursday october 9
october 19th august 19th 5
4 3 2 august 19th i will be at hyenas in
dallas
uh then i'll be at the state theater in
austin on august 20th
then i'll be at the rec room in houston
august 21st
then i'll be at the spokane comedy club
uh
thursday august 26th then i'll be at the
tacoma comedy club friday august 27th
and saturday august 28th
then i'll be at the stress factory in
new jersey those just dropped
um september 10th and september 11th
uh that's the stress factory in new
jersey and then i'll be in bridgeport
connecticut
what the [ __ ] are you doing dude what is
going on
why is he doing this
why just sit there and shut up
uh then friday october 1st and saturday
october 2nd i'll be at the stress
factory in bridgeport connecticut
and then this wednesday uh the 11th
of august i will be at uh the ventura
uh comedy the ventura harbor comedy club
in ventura california
and um come there there's a great lineup
but it's it's uh seven o'clock and uh
hopefully the cameras don't go to dave
anymore because that'll be problematic
i love it bro we're going to do a good
good show today look at you
yeah look at showing off the guns you
have a freckle line oh yeah no i have a
most people have a farmer tan but i have
a freckle
[Laughter]
those are some guns though huh they are
um
so planet change 10 the website is
actually happening
um it's done we're just now uh looking
for people
to help out on it and we'll start doing
meetings hopefully in these four cities
we go to
vegas phoenix denver and utah
salt lake city we can do some meetings
probably have to do them outside um so
it's like i said it's done me and the
the joshua's guy
who built it is awesome um we're getting
ready so
it's actually going to finally happen
after just so much nonsense
well and it's probably good timing a
good time
[Laughter]
why um everything's collapsing
june 4th 1999. i can't tell because i
don't read anything anymore
that's smart uh so look go to that go to
the
facebook page or the twitter and or
instagram and sign up and um
you'll get uh you'll get notifications
of what's going on so it's almost almost
ready to launch
okay anything else any aaron do you have
anything to say
uh i am worried about your power cable
right by your mic uh by the mic
of this oh no you don't want it near
that how's this
is this works
why are you worried
oh the power cable
i did it i moved it away what if i
needed the power cable to be right there
though
i i'm still not over the sleeveless
don't cancel me
come on guys it's just a power cable
shut the [ __ ] up about being canceled
seriously
january 24th 1895 year
of our lord jesus christ jesus christo
first for czechoslovakian speaking
friends
just get into it plenty wingo was born
to john newton and willie drusella
wingo in river red county texas
just the first part without the river
red county texas one more time just so
i'm locking
lenny wingo was born to john newton and
willie drusella wingo
to john and willie her name is willie
okay okay five months later
his dad came down with pneumonia and
died
okay so we got him out of the way how
nice
it's a nice turnaround too mike was
looking through the window at me that's
a nice turnaround though
his mom then married his dad's brother
sure and that's
what you do yeah absolutely the first
one was so great
it's close yeah it's close to what you
like the first time it's like getting a
new model of the car
yeah getting the spring 2022. a lot of
it's similar a lot of the body parts
yeah just a bigger screen maybe a little
you know better a little different head
maybe a little different head sure the
head stick is similar i would imagine
sure better
head what better head they had 10 more
kids
jesus uh as a child
plenty caught and sold rattlesnakes so
i'd say they made a little extra cash
you know
sold rattlesnakes as you do yeah no kids
love rattles
he waited tables as a teen and he fell
in love and married
idella who went by della okay quote
a hard-faced woman from hayes county
jesus what does that even mean
i don't know hard-faced yeah it's from
uh that quote us from author ben
montgomery unless you say otherwise all
quotes are from him
um i don't even know what that means
she's a hard face what does that mean
it's like a hard rockish okay sure so
rock like
sure she's got a bit of a shale head
it's a shell situation
right okay uh della and plenty then had
a daughter in 1915.
uh so plain is 20 years old and then
they opened a restaurant
in uh it's got to be different but dunny
it says here dunny texas
sure and then they moved to abilene and
opened another one there okay
uh so they're doing well sure and then
in 1928
plenty was arrested for selling quote
intoxicating liquor
at the restaurant oh and this is during
prohibition yeah right so that's
not okay it's not okay what a fun dance
we had
can you imagine being in this country
without access i wouldn't be surprised
if they brought it back
really the way everything's going things
are going pretty bad i mean they've
already stopped it on certain flights
right
there's certain planesworth i mean i
love that it's amazing
it really is amazing that we are at the
i mean we just keep taking it's just
incremental so it doesn't seem like a
lot but it's like man the wheels are
really coming off i mean they're
literally like
look you people are so [ __ ] crazy we
can't have alcohol on planes anymore
i mean they taped a guy and it was
justified
well then they then they suspended the
crew and everyone's like they're totally
right
but i mean can you imagine like if
you're on a plane getting duct taped are
you not like
i think i've lost the plot i don't think
i'd come off good in this no i don't
think it was that i think when i did it
it was different
it was different yeah it was different
uh so
he gets arrested now he he had to pay
bond to get out that's a lot of money
and that's like six months of profits
from the restaurant so he's in a hole
black friday came right depression's on
and pretty soon the bank took the
restaurant it's pretty amazing that
we've held up the
tradition of black friday but made it
different
something so awful in its own right
unless it's black tuesday did i say that
wrong whatever
uh he took it what monday it's black
monday right
yeah yeah it's black monday what's so
it's not the same okay
three monday is the day after sunday no
they do what do they do
well they do amazon monday or something
prime day prime day
prime day um he took a he took a job
at a cafe so he went from owning a
restaurant and now he's working at a
cafe for 17 cents an hour oh jesus
he's like a cook um then at vivian's
15th birthday party the kids
start talking about the the fad in
america of physical feats
so dance marathons swimming the english
channel pulsating walking on airplane
wings all that stuff
um americans just loves their minds they
just
love these people doing this stuff like
there was a guy who pushed a peanut
up a mountain with his nose i'm sorry
just let me say that again there was a
guy who pushed a peanut butter
with his nose a mountain yeah a mountain
it took him a long time
and he went through several shoes and a
lot of peanuts several shoes
and a lot of peanuts yeah so he's
allowed different peanuts you could
switch them out
but the whole idea is sub he's subbing
nuts the whole idea is you're pushing up
the mountain with your nose
he's subnetting yeah you can subnet
it's in the rulebook what if nightmare
why it's not a lie why did he do it
because
it was an ad for a peanut company
because everybody
everybody is like who's who's making
these peanuts like everybody cares about
which
i wonder how those taste you know i
didn't like peanuts until i saw that
gentleman pushing it up the
gentleman heroic hero
is
struck by this guy i mean i when i see
him i just what a legend a young young
woman 15
peanuts and he got all the way to the
top yeah
oh god i mel i melted when i said i lit
love and of course there was charles
lindbergh who's now flying around the
country on a victory tour and thousands
of people come out to see him
also in 1928 in january 1928
henry daredevil roland
climbed the nine-story mims building in
abilene as a huge crowd watched
we got to the top he threw out copies of
the abilene morning news because it was
an ad stunt right
i still am with the peanut guy yeah i'd
like now you push a peanut up that
building
i'm looking oh you know you push peanuts
anywhere and i'm in i'm listening with
your nose
peanut butter beetle nose you dung
beetle peanut no
i want nose you look a little bit like
wolverine i'm getting closer
not far away my hands have been hurting
uh so like i said americans love it and
he's like oh you can make money doing
this and then he's sitting at the party
he's seen his kids talk about it the
kids are like everything's been done
and he goes so he's listening to these
teenagers and he's like this is
he's like there there's a thing here
there's something and then he thinks i'm
gonna push a
peanut up a building with my [ __ ]
what if i walk around the world
backwards no dave come on
what does he know about water what is
the plan
i mean he's got jesus boots i'm sure
he'll take boats when he gets to the
well
he better be walking backwards the whole
goddamn voyage otherwise he's cheating
otherwise you just look for a circuitous
route that has no land no he would have
to walk backwards everywhere but yeah
okay now he told his wife she's she for
some reason is not down
so she's one of these people who doesn't
respect the dream of someone that she
loves
she's she's a dream killer what is her
problem with the plan that's good
why does she not uh oh it's something
about your husband saying he's gonna
walk around the world
backwards i mean it's it's gonna take
you away from the family but you also
have to understand the importance of
a mission and a mission is a mission to
walk around the world
not facing the direction you're going
that's important stuff
that needs to be done so here's what i'd
say i don't even know if it has to do
with walking around the world backwards
i think it's just the whole idea of
walking around the world
because that's going to take time she's
like that's going to take that's going
to be a timely
well backwards too it adds it's going to
add backwards months probably backwards
that's time
that's time it's probably it's probably
double or around although you could
probably get a pretty good clip going
yeah
you'll get used to it your head will
probably you'll probably be evolving in
ways
yeah you'll have a you'll have a linda
blair head from your arms will start
turning
yeah yeah and then once you start
putting your suit on backwards it's
really you're it's a matter of time
until people are like hey he's going
forward
no look at the elbows they're still
going backwards that man has just only
rotated his head
fully so uh
so she's not down and then he talks his
daughter into it she's like okay that
sounds like a good idea
mother's being a real you're natural
really [ __ ] about myself
i have something i need to tell you i um
talk to your mother and she's just being
a dream killer as usual
your dad wants to do something big for
you
so that you have a legacy okay um
and you know we were trying the
restaurants and then that unfortunately
i was giving people
liquor and i regret that but for the
bounce back
your old man's gonna walk around the
world
backwards what i'm gonna be gone for
about
five years six years and i'm gonna walk
i'll be like 20 when you get back and
but you'll be ready you'll be set up for
a better life because
you'll be associated with me people look
at you and they'll go that's the
daughter that
genius that walked around the globe
what's the wrong direction don't you
think they'll make fun of you for what
being a trailblazer
yeah no yes this is listen to me when
you have an idea
as airtight and perfect
hold on hold on airtight means yes it's
flawless
this is a let me all right let me ask
you this
ask what's the problem with it what name
one it sounds really [ __ ] stupid like
you sound like an idiot
well that's and a lot and i think dumb
but i think if you
if you were talking to einstein when he
was sort of first kind of
kicking around no it sounds like the
kind of thing that someone would come up
with when they were on cocaine
i do not do that drug much
and what i want you to know is that i'm
willing to pull the plug if it's not
working
but what i see is a a huge celebration
so i love you i don't i don't think you
do
i do i love you very much that's why i'm
going to walk around
the earth um with my head facing forward
and my legs going backwards what yeah
did you not pick up on that part i'm not
walking no
your body is changing well i hope it
will i'm hoping to adapt
none of this is a good idea every part
of it works in every way
and i'm gonna need less pushback from
you and that mother of yours who likes
to squash dreams
okay i think you should go all right now
watch how i go
backwards now get used to that i don't
want you gonna see that walking across
the sahara desert
i get thirsty so he goes to a doctor
so doctor i need to be psychiatrically
cleared and medically cleared for a
journey that's pretty bonkers
he tells the doctor's plan and the
doctor's like well
i'm in he says quote mr wingo if you
want to try it i'll be glad to give it
some thought and work out some exercises
to develop the muscles you'll need
like a lobotomy like like a lobotomy
like just taking an ice pick right in
what
what what so he's kind of found his
alfred
yeah well the doctor look the doctor's
gonna set him up with training
and uh the doctor's like i'm not gonna i
don't want any pay
you this is a great idea so why would
you pay me
um obviously i'm just in this because i
know how great this concept is
until he showed him some things to do to
build up such as what he was like
you're gonna need to your legs i'm gonna
be honest let's favorite building the
leg muscles
i assume we just had to walk backwards
there you go so this first one is called
this first training exercise we're going
to walk through is called the backwards
walk
and this is where you're going to walk
backwards and we're going to just kind
of keep doing this one for the most
part so really in a circle just you and
i'll both do it and i'm gonna time you
and then you're gonna try to beat that
time yeah
let's see how fast you can run a mile
so what about hurdles is that crazy so
he starts walking
and high jump he is holding up a mirror
like he's got his arm extended out and
he's holding the mirror
mirror he's well he has to or else how
is he going to know where he's going
well dave just walked forward for [ __ ]
sake can we have that conversation first
i mean he jumped nobody
at no point did he was he like i'll go
forwards and then he's like ah
i'm further like thought maybe i'll go
back like he right away just like
backwards
and then he see and then so so he's like
this hurt this is hard walking with my
arm out like this
and then he's looking in a magazine and
he's in is he doing it backwards he's
got the mirror he's like
what's that ad he sees no he's just
sitting down reading
he's an ad for uh sunglasses for
motorcycle
riders that have mirrors on the sides of
the glasses and he's like this is it
this is it at least the look is coming
together yeah
so you'd look at a guy crazy walking
backwards but if he has
side view mirrors on his head that's a
person cool that's a
cool guy so he buys them um it's gonna
take a long
he also takes money out of his savings
to buy them and then
takes a while to get there and by the
time the glasses get there he's been
training for weeks
weeks around the world it's all coming
together
weeks i don't know i mean again
obviously we don't know exactly
we haven't really charted this course a
lot but you know weeks
sure but you are trying to walk does he
know the world did they were they
familiar with the world
uh so he started pitching himself to
local businesses
and in fourth fort worth the
southwestern exposition
and fat stock show hired him you know
we've been looking for a fat stock
mascot for yeah we have
uh you look wonderful well my plan is to
walk backwards and i really think that
this and fat stock obviously pair
together greatly
you sorry well you have fat stock and i
think that uh
my walking backwards it makes me the
perfect spokesman
fat stock walking backwards
well they hired him of course and for 10
days he walked backwards around
fort worth and the whole area local
small towns
he got 250 for the 10 days and crowds
were get amazed the crowd started
gathering to watch him
wouldn't it be great to see what
happened if we never had tv or phones
yeah like what we would be watching now
yeah
yeah probably just public banging uh
people had questions they were like how
why are you doing it how did you learn
how to do it
how long have you been doing is your
brain intact what would happen
when you got to the ocean which was your
question well dave it's a fair question
because there's so much water on earth
uh and then of course backward backwards
walking man is in the papers the next
day
maps like knowing knowing where you're
go
like i mean it's quite a dis the
backwards part is really i feel like
gonna bite him in the ass
i really do we'll see i think it i think
it's fine okay it's funny
so the response to this is huge and the
stock show
breaks attendance records okay sure
right
so with his success uh plenty goes to
the chamber of commerce
in fort worth and he hold on my computer
backwards
and uh he says look i'm gonna walk
around the world backwards you guys
sponsor me give me 5k
i'll promote fort worth wherever i go
it's uh
it's an obvious absolutely obvious
partnership yes
how could it not taiwan he's walked all
the way to taiwan somehow
you guys ever heard of fort worth
do you want to get travel advice from a
man who has mirrors on his ears and is
walking backwards
but you know it's the depression so the
city has no money right uh chamber
commerce has no money
and he thinks about it and then he goes
oh
i will sell postcards as i walk i'll
sell them to people and that will be
my money to pay for the trip as i go
along let's i mean again i don't know if
we're trying to get back as fast as
possible but we're talking about adding
days and days and days to the trip now
if he's stopping selling merch
yeah he's merch but they're just
postcards still you're stopping
yeah and you're walking backwards yeah
daylight's your friend
yeah yeah i don't imagine a lot of night
backwards walking well you don't know i
hope not
and uh and so he sets off to walk around
the world backwards so he
leaves from fort worth um we still talk
so he's going forward
from abilene okay so he's going abilene
to abilene is the plan
yes and uh when he leaves he has
a blast is anyone going like a
yeah his wife okay
so all the things there's definitely
there's definitely who everyone's like
i'll go but everyone's also like what
the [ __ ] you doing not possible though
yeah
it's crazy his mom was just like oh
i'm worried thank god i had 14 others
so he leaves he has a black notebook to
keep records uh he has a pen
and a new bible that a street patron had
given him that's that's what he's
carrying that's it that's it he doesn't
have changes of clothes
no are you serious yeah yeah yeah yeah
that never comes up but that was a very
big concern of mine
he does not change his clothes he
had to smell so bad i mean just in
general you're just going to look
shipwrecked
yeah you don't ever want to knock i feel
like another set of pants or shoes i
would imagine
to pack a pair of shoes extra socks yeah
okay all right well i'll tell you what i
was dubious and now i'm
really really worried yeah so his
friends gathered and family
when he was setting off he shook their
hands and thanked them and then he
walked off backwards well if you excuse
me
i'm off i mean that first moment you're
like if that
that watch because usually when someone
walks away they walk away they turn and
they walk away but this is
so much more all right well
i'm about to go on the journey now okay
i will see you later take care everybody
i'll miss you okay bye looking good gang
okay bye see you later now okay all
righty
okay don't go in until you don't see me
anymore yeah
i i'm gonna turn around am i gonna hit
anything
no does anyone wanna come with me to
just sort of point out if i'm gonna hit
anything
that thank you sorry i don't mean to
come back but i'm thinking maybe i have
a person who comes with me
to see if i'm gonna hit anything yeah
yeah that would a spotter yeah spotter
you you know i don't want to go all
right take care everybody
so he was wearing shiny black shoes a
necktie
a homemade suit one size too large
i plan on growing he had he's five foot
four
okay okay he had the glasses with
mirrors and a cane with a
buffalo horn handle
all right oh no oh yes
oh my darshi blue it looks like what i
wore to prom
[Laughter]
yeah i mean around the world
yeah you don't think shorts shorts
and look at look at the i mean there
even though it's that time
there's no way there there weren't
better walking shoes i mean those are
like
no it's just i mean it's like like going
i'll be at a wedding in shoes like that
and by the end of the day i'll be like i
can't handle
anything they hurt he's deciding to walk
around the world
and dress little heels little heel
gestures and i was worried the glasses
would look crazy but then you see them
and you go oh actually they
they just they don't look but it looks
insane
yeah it looks insane
so oh my gosh he quickly as soon as he's
out of town
a guy stops him and he's like what are
you doing man what's going on
i'm trying to time's kind of a factor
for me do you want to buy a postcard if
not i have to keep
moving well he talks to the guy and
tells him uh the guy asked him the guy's
like how are you going to make money
and plenty says well i'm selling
postcards the guy goes i'll take one
but he doesn't have postcards yet
so he didn't have printed yet so he
takes the guy's address in his book and
he's gonna mail him one and the guy
pays him i i i am worried that we've
already lost
the the purpose of the mission he's now
already like
i can hang out in town for a little
while i'm getting them printed
and let me send you one so i said i owe
you
my now he's a banker it's like
so this so this happens for a while he's
just writing people's names down taking
money and he's going to send him a
postcard and people are doing it
sometimes people are he says i'll do it
for free he
it's charity he's like you know whatever
you want to pay
so some people give him a buck and some
people get 25 cents and some people are
just can you send me one and he goes
yeah yeah i guess
but after a while he realized oh i
should actually just charge them amount
so he starts charging people 25 cents
okay now people would ask to try out his
cane and his glasses and he would always
say yes
oh my god he's saying yes for a while
after a while
i got a guy i can't i have a family
my daughter's furious my wife doesn't
believe in me
by the way i'm still an abilene
it's been six days it's been six days i
haven't left my i can still see my wife
she's furious i think i'm actually gonna
walk home for the night
i just give it up with so many postcards
for future postcards
so the idea was he would go into a town
and he'd go to the western union
office and the guy there would stamp and
sign his book with a date and time
and then and then once that happened he
could walk forward and spend the night
in a hotel or whatever so and then the
next day he would start from the west
union office
walking back so he has he he is able to
break backward character for a while and
walk
forwards once he's she's so he's he's
clocking in and out
oh thank god i can walk forward again
he's clocking out well it's a job to him
he's clocking out
weird job so
dallas doesn't allow people to carry
signs and he had a sign on his back that
said around the world backwards
[Music]
outside dallas he stops at a gas station
he needs a friend
he needs a friend he needs someone to
just be a pal and shoot him straight
as it does he stops again walking around
the world backwards
you imagine seeing him
he calls the mayor from a gas station
hello mr mayor
um it's me plenty i'm walking backwards
i'm in your town
and the mayor's like what a great idea
it'll be no problem here you can
actually wear your sign here because
this is a great idea what you're doing
and when he arrived the mayor would send
a cop
to the border and he escorts him through
dallas
because a giant crowd swells when they
see him sure
people are coming out to look at him i
would yeah
backwards i would and i would i would go
up to him i'd be like buddy come on
let me buy a coffee let's talk for a
minute so not a life
they follow him to the western union he
goes inside and then he comes out
walking forwards and the crowd starts to
boo
but now i'm out of character i'm regular
i'm
a regular guy now come on
so he explains to the crowd how it works
and then they're like oh okay
sorry we booed we didn't understand your
weird
quirks and sort of out yeah i didn't
know because it's a dumb thing and
you're making up your own rules so i
guess it makes sense
it makes sense but it's super weird all
of it's really weird
i think you think it'd be better if you
walked around backwards all the time i
agree with him i think even at night you
should walk backwards and i think you
should sleep on your head
yeah but whatever it's your own thing i
would you know okay
thanks anyway cool do we clap or what
i don't know he owes me nine postcards
i don't want one i don't either really
i'm not yeah the whole thing seems kind
of sad
jody postcards in the grand canyon
where's his wife
so the dallas morning news writes up a
story about this guy
he finally in dallas gets postcards
printed
he splits them half he can't afford them
so he have time for tasks like this
he can't he he pays the guy half
and then when he makes enough money he's
gonna send money and the guy will
forward them to whatever town he's in
the other half hard to know where he'll
be for sure yeah but
i think he'll be in two weeks he's hard
to say he's having all his mail
forwarded so he'll go to a town and go
to like dallas and go okay now i'm here
can you forward it to
whatever oklahoma and oklahoma city and
that's all that's what he's doing yeah
no and it's his only connection to his
family yeah
probably important i would imagine so
he's got the postcards and he's like i
got that to cover traveling cosplay i
just need a sponsor
and that'll be to for my family to make
the money for my family
that's what the whole plan is to get a
sponsor and make the big cash and then
after he's done he wants to sell a book
and become super rich sure
so he leaves dallas he's not always well
well received in the
small town of allen he backed into a
general store
and an employee started screaming at him
he backed into
yeah he's walking backwards into the
store he has to walk backwards until he
gets
union so he walks down the store he's
got to walk around the store back into a
guy
what are you doing he's like read the
sign pal i'm on a bit of a mission
the guy the employee of the store yelled
quote stop that nonsense and get out of
here
we don't allow backwards walkers in this
stout
so he hustles away and then as he's
walking away he heard he didn't just
hear
he could have seen her because he's
walking backwards a woman comes out of
the store and
yells at him come back oh god i gotta
get yeah i gotta hustle he hustled i
gotta hustle backwards
so this woman comes out she's the owner
of the store and she's like you're the
man walking around the world
come on come here oh thank you and uh
the guy who yelled at him then buys a
postcard i'm sorry i didn't know that
you were the guy walking backwards i
thought you were a guy walking backwards
and sherman when he checked out of his
hotel they told him he didn't have to
pay
so people are like oh taking care of him
sure uh he walked 109 miles in his first
week
i mean that is a lot it is a good amount
it's a very good amount for walking by
yes that's a lot
now for the first time in his life he
left the state of texas
in oklahoma papers across the u.s and in
europe
printed pictures of mr plenty wingo as
he walked backwards
so it's in his one suit it is one suit
how's that suit smelling not good
it's terrible it's not good
in the right direction he's
yeah he's that it's i think he's
following uh
he's just on a highway so i don't know
where he is he's following highways
yeah he's just following the highway so
just gonna take the 95
down to louisiana and then hopefully get
into the
oh god i'm in oregon oh god no
no how did this happen oh no
i walked 109 miles in the wrong
direction backwards
in moscow muskogee
muskogee in muskogee i always thought
that was in florida
in muskogee a man asked him what shoes
he wore
plenty quote it's a good brand but until
some shoe company
decides to sponsor me no one will ever
know what kind of shoes i wear i like
the move
and the man was like fair enough i like
the move i like the move he is
he's a walking nascar yeah he's i like
that
and the next day some teens see him and
they're driving along beside him and
they start yelling at hey why don't you
walk
forward to the old piece of [ __ ] what
tough tough gig you got buddy
all right you've had your fun kids get
moving that's basically exactly what it
was all right we had a good time
i remember when i was your age and i
used to see dreamers and i used to mock
them too but
get moving come on now by the way which
way is
oklahoma oh you're in it oh thank god
uh one of the loudest kids in the car is
challenged by his buddies to keep up
with plenty for a mile
so kid gets out and starts walking
beside him backwards all right come on
there's only room for one of us doing
this come on makes it a half mile and
gives up
ah see you later quitter which raised
china oh
the boy quote you can have all the
backward walking i don't want it
i don't want to get back when walking
mister
so outside st louis
good lord so now he's like going curving
up he doesn't know where he's going he
can't see where he's going he's
following highways
i feel like he's on route 66 it's always
been a dream of mine to walk it
backwards
so outside saying there's a car pulls
over and two men get out
hey why don't you try walking forward
yeah they start chatting
they're talking for all they're very
nice and this happens all the time so
it's not unusual
and then one of the guys asks he asks
plenty if he can carry him a short
distance
can i carry you would you mind getting
in my arms and i'll carry you for a
little bit
he's pushing it yeah i don't know come
on i sound a little uncomfortable
well i just you need a break i'll walk
backwards when i carry you no i need a
break but that's
it's weird i'm trying to get publicity
by carrying a guy walking backwards
across the world
so oh you should have said that right
away i didn't know you were getting in
my eyes
okay all right here we go oh my god i
feel like a baby feels good right yeah
this is nice
i should get a bjorn for you oh we could
do one of those i would love that can i
uh
nurse yes please please please have
where do i do that um the penis seems
good i gotta go
okay so when he asks him if he can carry
him plenty says quote i don't know what
your point is but
if you promise not to harm me i guess
it'll be okay god
he's like a circus animal so the man
scoops him up
what is with this guy he starts he's got
a really weird
little dream he carries him the way a
groom would carry a bride right across
the threshold
and he carries him about 20 feet and
then he turns around and comes back and
puts him down
oh uh he's like i thought you were going
to advance me it's like nah
you're right back where you started and
i don't want you to have an asterisk
next to your walk around the world
backwards goal
and then the guy lifts up his pant legs
his pant legs or plenty's pant legs now
his own pants
and reveals that he has two prosthetic
legs oh wow okay
and he's a rep for a prosthetics company
and said
if plenty loses a leg on the journey
he'd help him get a new one
wink wank you willing to uh
play the game what a crazy offer
plenty we would love to sponsor you with
our prosthetic legs
nothing's going to stand in the way
other than the two real legs you're
using
we'd like to get rid of them we're going
to cut off what are your legs we want to
cut off put one of these bad boys on
there and see how far you get
i like the insinuation too like if an
accident were to
find your calf if you catch my drift
so plenty thanks and he's like wow
that's really nice it's a really crazy
offer he goes uh uh on his way
uh when he gets to sing those people are
looking for him they're waiting they
know he's coming to st
louis they'd read about him and he feels
like a big deal when he gets there
people are like oh it's the walking
backwards guy
hey something to do today but he still
needs a sponsor right
and uh back home as brother and father
they they've started picking cotton to
make money because things are so bad
he's not gonna cut his leg off is he and
della's letters
are seeming very distant david david
david you do not take a cut your leg
off offer he promised her he would
turn this into a fortune he's promising
his wife this is going to be our fortune
st louis is the shoe manufacturing
center of the world
okay so he goes to every shoe company
in st louis okay nobody is interested
that's crazy to me
isn't it yeah that's totally like
because the the mission is absolutely
stupid yes but the plan of getting
publicity out of it clearly works
clearly works yeah and he could say i'm
wearing yeah and he was nike
yeah and everywhere he went and people
would be like oh it's a nice yeah it's
the air [ __ ]
100 would totally work um so while he's
there
he meets this it's a lonely rich guy
it's a rich guy his family left him a
long time ago but he's super rich hello
plenty stays in his mansion you stay
here with me
we are friends all i have are rooms
do you want to hang out with an old man
who loves your walking backwards you can
walk sideways here i won't tell
i need a smithers hello
um so the guy takes him all over he go
he takes him to his first professional
baseball game
this is the baseball game oh the
cardinals beat the giants in that one
[ __ ] you
aaron um hell yeah and uh they go to his
speakeasy he just takes them all over
he's just paying for him and they're
having a good time let's get drunk
and you're the best friend i've had
since my family left
what an odd duo eh who'da thunk it
an old rich man alone no yeah and a guy
who has
crazy glasses with mirrors walking
backwards around the world in one suit
with a bible and postcard
okay i just got to take off i need
someone to wash my behind
i really gotta go exactly but wash it
backwards then you can do it
oh we had a great
time i mean we i mean our
best up until a point friends no
you know what i'm coming with you no
no no no follow you no no you're good
you got we got this
wrapped up i'll drive it we're not
driving i'll get on your back
we'll do it together like we always do
the duel
plenty and gramps back at it again we're
doing it one more
time i can't i'll tell you one thing
plenty
i'm getting a little too old for this
[ __ ] i am i'm kidding though i want to
do it no
i just come on you'll die i'm dying now
i gotta go i have days left okay bye bye
so when he leaves the guy gives him an
envelope
and he goes only open this when you're
really desperate okay i'll open it right
now
and i'm desperate uh in he
he he leaves saint louis he gets an east
st louis
and an angry cop storms up to him quote
you can't walk backwards here cops
come on cops would you be chill for once
you can't walk hey buddy come on
i got a 419. we got a guy walking
backwards he shouldn't be
got beard glasses we ain't this kind of
[ __ ] town buddy hey you won you're
walking backwards why don't you go back
to saint louis you're an e
saint louis now jagoff so plenty
explains him what he's doing because
it's
it's a whole thing i'm doing and the
cops like look you might get hurt
look i'm not letting you do it
look i know you've been walking
backwards for a while now you're lucky
you ain't gotten hurt
your [ __ ] dream's over kids all right
now walk forwards home
so plenty picks up a rock and he draws a
line on the sidewalk with it
and then he walks to city hall and talks
to the police chief
and the chief just laughs because the
chief's like i've been reading about you
and the papers i know who you are
and the police chief writes him a note
saying he can walk backwards anywhere in
east st louis
and then plenty goes back to the place
where he
drew the line and starts walking
backwards again
[Laughter]
and then the cop sees him hey hey hey
hey we talked about this i
i one more time you're going to jail the
right way you shitty [ __ ]
you city folk think you can come here
walking backwards
so he starts screaming at him he runs
over and grabs him by the collar and
starts shaking him
and he's like you're not walking
backwards in my town
and plenty takes out the note and shows
them and the cops like all right go
ahead there are other officers
let this guy walk backwards chief
wow that's pretty airtight
and the cop says quote all right go
ahead and break your full neck for all i
care and then he lets him go thank you
the next day the st louis star printed
the story about his run-in with the cop
it's just so it would have been great if
you had to run away from the cop jeez
this isn't easy this isn't easy this
isn't easy
so he goes to chicago his aunt lives in
chicago that's why he's going there
because it's
a way out of the way no but dave when
you have family
you have to stop by or it's rude whether
you're driving flying or walking
backwards on foot
i mean he essentially he he moved you
went east a little bit and
just went north no it absolutely makes
no sense
so as he's walking to chicago through
illinois a patrolman stops him highway
patrol
and says there's a law against walking
backwards on illinois roads
how is there a law there isn't they just
make it's not a law
it's not a thing it's it's like there's
no way it's happened before no never
yeah this is the first and the cops [ __ ]
gives them a warning and says quote
don't let me catch you on again
you better be walking forwards if i see
you i see you again kid you better be
walking forward
it's over for you look you go to a lot
of towns you can walk forward you can
walk backwards
in chicago it's still windy i put a lot
of guys in the clink for this [ __ ]
i've seen some of the best minds of my
generation killed by walking backwards
and i'm not gonna go through that again
you know how this capone guy started
backwards that's right it was backwards
al capone was a backway he's called
backwards capone at very
beginning yeah they called him
no poc that's right backwards yeah
i gotta go yep we're taking off i'm not
good at these things
so so he gets to his aunt he gets to his
aunt's house
hey i'm crazy hi aunt grace he's
exhausted
but she's like i'm inviting over a
reporter so she has a reporter come over
from the chicago daily news and he's
like
i got a pitch newsreels we want to make
a news reel
about you walking backwards great so
they film it it's just him in different
places chicago walking backwards
wrigley field and he watches himself
michigan street
he watches himself on june 25th in a
movie theater before the movie
he watches the newsreel and now he's
like i'm definitely getting a sponsor
now
and this [ __ ] is blowing up past blowing
up and uh he needed it because della has
stopped writing back to him
okay well she might just not know the
address where he's walking
no everything is getting forwarded i
know
it's still crazy i know again
no one in chicago wants to sponsor crazy
he keeps notes on people he speaks to
just the random people he's running into
like uh he meets cg work who had a big
two-wheel bicycle that was really fun
in indiana he met farmer tim forster and
they had a quote
tree discussion i get why his wife's
pissed
he's not hustling there's no hustle he's
talking about trees to strangers
in ohio he spoke to thomas mcgorvey who
had been quote convicted for
manslaughter that's interesting
yeah yeah so there's a lot he's just
that's what he's doing he's just walking
backwards and people
stop and talk to him and he writes
manslaughter huh i'm gonna stop for a
minute that's interesting tell me about
that tell me about how you killed the
fella
outside of canton ohio he's walking and
he's looking at the traffic and he steps
into a hole
it's about goddamn time
[Laughter]
from the sound he knew instantly his
ankle was broken oh no
oh no no doc set the foot going the
other way if you can
it'll be really good yeah just turn it
around break the other one and then turn
it the other way too
please can you do the whole leg
the man asks if he a man stops and asks
if he needs an ambulance and penny's
like i
i plan he's like i can't afford
absolutely oh so
it's kind of nice to hear that like
america has been consistent yeah there's
nothing
ever changed the first thing you worry
about when you get hurt is don't call it
ambulance
oh god no i'd rather die here somebody
don't call 9-1-1
so the guy called the sheriff and they
take him to a hospital
and he has taken a mercy hospital which
is run by nuns
and they treat him and they let him stay
there for free until he heals which is
three weeks
because he's the guy walking backwards
yeah i get it but his wife is just like
jesus christ i mean it's over right
she's already remarried well so he's
ready to go again
right and he starts walking he well he
doesn't start walking he leaves the
hospital he goes back to the hole
and he steps in it and then starts
walking backwards damn it's like a it's
like a golfer like no no i don't cheat
well he's worried that someone's going
to catch him right but the idea that
someone is watching him this close
no no one's yeah
so he's heading east he's very worried
that della is not riding him back
yes i think i might need to walk home
for a minute and he gets to west
virginia
he starts running out of money because
people in west virginia are just
basically driving by him and yelling at
him to get out of the [ __ ] road
and no one's buying his postcards nice
so he opens the envelope okay 20 bucks
okay and that keeps him he was gonna
have to sleep on the road that night
okay so that keeps him from sleeping on
the road all right
and then he bumps into a guy do you feel
like it's worth it dave
a yeah yeah are a man's dreams worth it
is that what you're asking
you're right oh yeah very unfair very
unfair so
he bumps into a guy who literally is
selling
liquid sulfur cure so it's a liquid it's
like one of those
many concoctions that people are selling
right makes your nipples hard gives you
hair on your dick all the things you
need all right what
wait it turns your feet backwards makes
you want it oh that one
makes your family forget you tried to
walk backwards around for a year i want
that one too
it gives you normal-looking glasses and
it lets your suit not smell like
horseshit oh that's me
yes well then you're gonna want this
dual tonic right here it's all in one
so he pays plenty 25 to walk around town
wearing an ad board for his cure
so he makes he makes money that's a lot
of money sure so he's got like 45 bucks
okay and he starts writing in his
journal all the things he could do with
his money
including sending it to della and and
his daughter sure
but it says he says he got quote stuck
at a resort
in breezewood pennsylvania
so so
in a way he doesn't want to go home oh
yeah right yeah
oh yeah he's like yeah he he's
[Laughter]
he's a road comic making up gigs yes he
is yeah no i'm gonna be in a
television that's an
be in delagon unedited a show we're
doing the delagong improv
yep real big good gig could be great
don't look it up in any way no it's not
it's off
it's off the map yeah
secret yep secrets did you not know
about secret states
the united states is actually 61 states
that's right a bunch of them are
shushers
there's only one's just for comedians
yep that's what i'm going to delagong
so he's at this resort and he gets a
letter from della
okay she's not written him now in 50
days
okay quite a long time when you're alone
walking backwards yeah
and she's like i'm sick of your dumb
project i'm
barely getting by your plan's not gonna
work
and you need to come home now his
daughter
also writes a letter and says mom's
losing weight
and she's nice that's good to hear
sounds like things are going great at
home
anyway i'll just continue on with my
normal dream
glad everything's working out great
there i got stuck in a resort if you'll
believe that what a nightmare
pictures send the pictures of mom in
this
hot new look mom's gaunt all right
i love god i love god that's my thing
uh so the daughter basically is like
this is your fault
how is this my fault
the nerve you don't talk to your father
like that
what did i do i've been passive in this
whole situation you left us and walked
backwards
in a lot of ways it felt like the house
you lived and walked backwards and left
me
that doesn't even make sense well a lot
of it doesn't make sense
now i think we're all saying the same
thing no we're just keep going
not at all i will we're saying the
opposite i'll finish this
we're saying i'll see you in greece come
home
now your marriage is on the line i can't
i have a mission
this mission chose me fam
chose me so he
by the way do you guys need a tonic
elixir no it's an
all-in-one no i heard it makes your
nipples hard puts hair on your dick no
okay so plenty is absolutely devastated
by these letters
but what does he expect i don't know i
mean
he didn't it didn't feel like he had
support when he left no he didn't
he did not like what he expects it to go
like they're gonna get
that's gonna they're gonna get more into
it i do think he expected a sponsor and
he would be able to send him money and
they'd be like yeah and probably maybe
he would expect bigger
press and yeah and i'm surprised and
he's getting a good amount he's getting
a very good amount
i think we're about surprised he didn't
get a sponsor yes i am surprised
um so he gets the letters he's
devastated and then he sets off and
walks backwards toward washington dc
[Music]
just a man just walking slowly down the
road crying
yeah crying just like
i love him i miss him i just wish
i'm gonna when i get when i get to the
end they're gonna love me
they'll be so proud
[Laughter]
so in delaware cobb yelled at him for
walking backwards
of course as he left the town the next
nothing else to do
as he left on the next one a different
cop yelled quote
get out of town we didn't allow folks
like you here oh my god
goddamn freak he's experiencing walkism
you're gonna ruin our kids down lexie
and you're kind of walking around here
excuse me fella you look like you might
be lost
actually i'm incredibly lost i have no
clue where i am i've been walking
backwards i don't know where i've got
highway
i'm trying to do a highway i keep
looking at this map and then walking
backwards and not knowing what in the
[ __ ] is happening have you ever tried to
follow a map
while walking backwards no gimme
no no gimme no gimme
so he gets to new york unbelievable he
walked all the way to new york
and now it's time for the underwater
walk
um so and the fish are like
so he knows a guy in new york because a
guy he went to high school with
left the town and now works at the saint
regis hotel in new york
okay so fancy [ __ ] hotel sure and the
guy's like you can stay with me because
i guess he's but you gotta walk in the
hotel
just in the hotel jesus christ can you
just please
um so he stays with him
and they start looking up all the shoe
manufacturers
in new york no one will sponsor him
i feel like he's blacklisted or
something i feel like big shoes working
against him
i wonder if they meet him and there's
something off
explain what that could be a man who
smells terrible with backwards glasses
what do you think is the red flag they
say
what i'm very curious what you would
think the problem would be
oh i gotta check my wife check your wife
that she's uh
stuck in an airport oh which one um
she's in line between two genziers who
are yelling at their parents because
they aren't going to make their
connections
yelling this whole thing was mom's idea
oh
yes she's 100 getting stuck in denver
okay cool oh i was just there it's great
tell her to go look at the crazy [ __ ]
i'm telling you terminal b oh yeah so
um so yeah so they're trying all these i
mean you know there's a million places
in new york i mean just no success
he also needs money to give a great if
like a platform shoe or a high heel
company was like we're interested
uh ladies high heels sounds a little
tough i guess i'll give it a shot have
you heard of stripper shoes
uh i'll try this is adding months
ow i re-broke it
um he also needs a ticket to get on a
ship to go to europe he doesn't have
enough money
to get on a ship so
the brooklyn eagle writes a story about
him and said he was trying to get to
england still
nobody comes forward and he starts
thinking about giving up he's like is
this
dream sometimes i feel like this dream
is just crazy
isn't that nuts because it's not it's
it's an amazing dream i wouldn't give it
it's a good dream yeah yeah it's
the best dream some people are like i
wanna i wanna be a professional
basketball player some people like oh my
god what if i was an actor everyone's
doing movies
yeah i mean that's the thing everyone's
doing that or someone's like i want to
be the best cowboy or
you know there's all kinds of dreams
some guys are just like i want to be a
good janitor or you know
really solid dreams but you're just like
i want to you know
do something that seems so good
everyone thinks it's great yeah yeah and
so
you know everyone's really impressed
with it
yeah they're looking at me going like
there's the guys gets it
and it's right on the money yes just do
it right
amazing plenty anyone could be this dumb
call him
plenty because he's got plenty of good
ideas [ __ ] for brains
pretty good his brains are good i agree
got good grades yep great stuff
i'm happy to hear it back
so so he he feels bad that he's living
with his buddy in the hotel so he gets a
job in a cafeteria
and and takes a room in a boarding house
dave i did not think there would be
job breaks i didn't either but there are
oh i guess i gotta work
i gotta work at a cafe for a year
[Laughter]
yeah i got away from the kidnapping i'm
interning at rolling stone i'm not sure
what's happening but i will get back to
it i swear to god hon
and then one day he meets a guy named
alexander schwartz
and they start talking and plenty tells
him about his situation
quote he says i've tried about
everything i can think of except maybe
walking around the empire state building
and then schwartz yells
that's it you genius you've cracked it
schwartz knows a guy who works at the
empire state building and he's like i
can get you on the roof
plenty would walk around the top while
a wire is holding him so he doesn't fall
off
and no one down below can see literal
nightmare no one down below could see it
and then everyone on the street will
chair and they'll sell ads to this
show event they'll make money
so they go down to the empire state
building and they tell the guy the idea
the guy just laughs he takes them up
there and
it's so windy there's no one anyone no
no way pot
you cannot do it it's like completely
physically impossible
so then schwartz go hey what about the
what if you should die
doing it yeah what if you then we get a
coffin monster
and on the way down we'll be like this
is the one of the first guys to fall
backwards
to his death yeah yeah so he's like what
about the hershtower in elizabeth new
jersey
it's 14 stories okay right
so they go and they look at it and like
yeah let's do it the building's like
yeah you can do that
um so they started looking for sponsors
in elizabethtown
all the businessmen seem to know
schwartz and not like schwartz
interesting but they agree
they'll sponsor it only if they pay
afterwards they're not going to pay him
before
not a red flag did you say it was red
flag well i'm
but if i were a computer my pinwheel
would be spinning yes
so he walks around elizabeth
backwards elizabeth town is losing town
or elizabeth i think he said elizabeth i
think it's just elizabeth uh whatever
so he walks around the town backwards
with an advertising board on that's
going to do this
event right crowd gathers
sure gets up on the roof
starts walking backwards now it has
like architectural things that
that come up and block the way of the
walkway so
so he's got like little things to worry
about so he's got to walk backwards and
then when he gets to them the whole
crowd gasps
and then he has to climb over it
backwards and every time he got over one
they would all cheer
okay and then he walks the complete walk
imagine giving him an iphone
the crowd goes [ __ ] bananas they're
just like this
is amazing holy [ __ ] they have to invent
television they have to
invent television we need something to
do
ridiculous
and then he's done and schwartz is gone
good and so he waits for schwartz
dinner they're supposed to have he
doesn't show up he doesn't come to the
hotel
next day he goes to see the businessman
schwartz already collected the money
great okay good well there we go that's
good that worked out great
86 great didn't need that so that's cool
plenty realizes he's been scammed he's
really bummed sure
he's like well i can get something out
of this i'll go to her's tower and ask
the manager for a letter of endorsement
like you know this guy does a good job
with his back this guy is uh
if i was ever going to hire someone who
just walked backwards it would no doubt
be this
this is the guy uh there's two of those
there's two others oh yeah yeah
randy's really randy's unbelievable yeah
i would do it with randy i know the
randy
so as he he gets into the top of the
building and there's schwartz
okay and schwartz runs into another
office and hides for a while and then
and then easy to outrun a guy walking
backwards he's not walking backwards
i'll get you i'm ready but he's probably
like atrophied now he's like i don't
know how to go forward
no i think when he walked forward it was
weird ow owie
so he waits in the stairwell because he
knows that schwartz will probably try to
escape
down the stairwell and he does and he
beats the [ __ ] out of schwartz
he's just seems so out of character i
know totally out of character
he's just punching and punching he's not
just punching schwartz he's punching his
making he's punching the no-shoe
sponsors his wife is punching his wife's
anger towards him he lost the rest of
the disappointment of his daughter
yeah the loss of his restaurant schwartz
must be old because he punches
schwartz's dentures out
well dave he's old and finally
schwartz is like the money's all gone i
don't have any of the money good
he reaches in his pocket he takes out
six crumpled dollars
left plenty starts hitting him again
schwartz runs and he makes it out to the
sidewalk and flags down a street cop
and then plenty is arrested for
aggravated assault
just took a dark turn yeah just took a
dark turn
okay can you cuff me in the front
because the way i do this
it will be my back if you think about it
it'll please do it that's my back it's
technically better
front to back please so
he gets he gets put in jail then all the
local businessmen who hate schwartz they
hear
and they come and they bail him out oh
okay like thanks for beating the [ __ ]
out of that guy
basically and then they go to a hearing
and at the hearing
schwartz is suing plenty
for his dentures which he never got back
the dentures were knocked out and yeah
but he had 80 dollars
right and the judge is like okay [ __ ]
you no one's getting fined you both just
get out of here this is the dumbest [ __ ]
i've ever heard
it does sound like a people's court case
it's like it's on the level of insanity
that i would expect it to be
either unlike judge judy or greg mathis
like it's not a regular case it's like
the defendant is suing the backwards
walking man for denture assault
in a stairwell uh
so he now heads for boston because
someone
had told him of a shoe
soul making company that might sponsor
him there okay and
he goes through providence and in
providence there's a letter waiting for
him at the post office
his wife it's from della i've got a good
feeling yes she wants a divorce
what about this doesn't work for her i
don't know why is she so difficult
women are so selfish when it comes to
support a dream
thank you i can't do this without you
della
i asked if you wanted to walk backwards
around the world with me and you said
that was crazy too
so he signs the divorce papers and um
he keeps moving on man can you imagine
being single on this journey oh [ __ ]
look out hello talk about lady pyle
backward banging so he's not wearing
shorts
no that's not dyla um
so he he starts wearing shorts
okay uh which the boston clothes boy
somebody's single
which the boston globe called quote
sawed off
knee pants they've never heard of shorts
it's the best
they've never doesn't matter it's the
best should i wear pants or my sawed-off
knee
shorts to the beach does anyone have any
thoughts just let me know
sawed off
[Laughter]
now his legs so his calves are basically
on the front i uh my god yes
yeah his like literally he builds up
that area that muscle is right
enormous and then out back is nothing
yeah compared
right right yeah he's like i mean he's
developing excuse me freak coming
through
frank put some goddamn pants on you're
scaring the children
the dogs the dogs are scared of you
these are sawed-off pants
jesus christ this is all crazy so he
gets to the guy at the shoe company in
boston and the guy's like
i can't well i walked quite a distance
backwards for this meeting yeah it's not
it's not something i would really love
you to reconsider i i've walked
your legs are upsetting in a way that
i've never thought like i want to throw
up
like a deer relax i don't want to calf
shame but you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ] up
you're [ __ ] you're a
look at the front of my life you should
not be look at the front of my legs you
should not be wearing shorts or sawed
off pants they're sawed off pants you
shouldn't be wearing sawed-off knee
pants
well i mean i don't know what look let's
we got off on the wrong foot
but uh um why why your feet actually
turned the wrong way
that was they reset it the wrong it's
i'm evolving in a way that's
different it's not good for business
it's not bad for business what i'm
suggesting here is that you
have a one-of-a-kind model here
with me and what i am pitching
is that we get into the shoe biz
you got souls i got goals let's do this
i don't want to let's start from the top
again okay from the topic i would like
to not let you in my office you wouldn't
say that
i cannot you
are those even cabs anymore they're what
do you call them
leg parts they're back legs they're the
back it's not back legs it's a front i
have fraps it's a front it's a front
calf it's a fraff
it's not it's it is have you never seen
a guy who looks like he has his butt up
front
no oh well you got to meet my friend
rich he's got trump
jesus christ i wanted him to come with
me i feel like you
i feel like there's this should less be
about
us advertising with you and more about
getting you into a mental hospital
i what shoe would i wear there that's
what i'm saying let's
join ours we're not
i know a banana company because you're
going bananas
i'm going through a divorce
so after that one i took a sip
yeah my wife uh
has some uh smarts issue with yeah she's
a smart lady
i've been gone about a year yeah i'm
still in america so barely
six more to go so
but the guy at the shoe company he's
like we got a shipping guy maybe he can
help you get
on a ship to england
so it would have been good to plan some
of this
so on january 12 1932 the guy calls him
up and he goes
i can get you to europe but it's going
to be germany and he's like okay that's
fine i'll walk there
so on june 12 1932 he gets on the
seattle spirit
ship and he's headed for hamburg germany
very quickly is he
is is he trying to do the most land
possible or at this point he's just sort
of like whatever i can get most land
possible okay
so when he gets on board he comes on
board and he says to the crew quote
hello hello everybody
here i am bad idea but
the semen are like uh yeah uh the crew
already knew he was getting passengers a
favor ship steward doesn't like it
nobody likes it but also think of how
crazy he looks he's got that weird zoot
suit on he's out he's wearing shorts
he's got his crafts
yeah the glasses the crazy glasses
and then he announces it's like yeah
dude we know it's you yeah
we knew it was you when we saw you
walking backwards up the ramp
to the ship guess who's here it's me
backwards guys anyone on the ship
who wants a weirdo in their cabin hello
so they the stewart tells them he has to
squeegee 14 cabins
that's not that's going to take like
days and days and days like he's got a
squeegee 14 cabin so
the first day he gets really seasick
he's in his bunk vomiting for four days
but the steward's still making him get
up and work
he's got more so he was squeegeeing and
then vomiting where he squeegeed and
then that's tough for business yeah
it's just like wait it'll be like
watching a window washer just throwing
up on the windows he's cleaning
oh no during
uh that time as he's laying there sick
one of the crew comes in and he starts
talking to him and he's being really
nice
caring you know and at one point
planning tells the guy
he goes i was told i wouldn't have to
work that much on this trip
and now i'm having to work all the time
and that guy
was just a snitch he was the steward's
assistant he goes to tell the steward
stewart is
[ __ ] livid so he's complaining yeah
and he tells plenty you're gonna work
eight hour days every single day until
you get off this goddamn [ __ ]
no and the steward just like hates it
more and more every day
and then one day he goes look i might
not release you when we get to germany
i might not let you go what and then
plenty goes to the camp and he goes is
that
something that can happen and the
captain's like yeah yeah yeah now you
can uh
live here forever if we want you to so
did you not know that that's a ship did
you not know ship rules yeah the whole
thing is that
uh if we choose to have ownership over
you we can yeah it's like slavery so
we're doing that so yeah yeah anyway hey
you walked really far though
yeah you had a good run all right
when they land in hamburg germany
the stuart's like i'm going to italy
it's like 20 somewhat days or something
and he puts his assistant in charge of
plenty they have plenty of passport
so he needs to they do have him yes and
he's like he gives him a job to do he's
like you got to do all this work before
you can go
and um he tells the guy only give it to
plenty when he's done with his work
so he's working like crazy
and after all these days he finally gets
his uh passport back okay now while he
was working he found some lie
okay and once he gets his passport back
he ha he took he had taken some of the
lie
and he goes into the stewards cabin
before he leaves the ship
and he puts the lie in his bed oh jesus
so the irony and then he gets up the
ship and he goes to a
he finds a boarding room in town
avoiding the hotel
in the area where he knows the crew is
staying yeah of course
stewart comes back that night oh i'm
just gonna have a lie down
takes a shower oh i want to get nice and
clean before i get into bed
and then gets into bed and starts
[ __ ] screaming ah yeah
skin is burning but it's losing [ __ ]
crazy move
he knew he knew right away who had done
it i've got my passport i guess i'm just
going to chemically burn the captain
and he goes looking he so he goes
looking for plenty because he's
going to kill plenty and
was it that's purely a revenge move he
could have just snuck off the ship
no but the i mean he was done basically
the steward was being a [ __ ] monster
so yes but i mean you could have just
walked yes he could have
this was a this is like i don't like you
i do like that he's beating people and
he's making lie beds yeah he's
definitely
he's definitely getting a little he's
finding his courage yes he's like the
lion and the yes yeah is it the lion
that gets his courage
the lion gets his courage he's the
cowardly mind what does the clown get
the clown the clown the clown was
murdered in the first half the clown was
murdered
in the first pack but the monkeys they
just ravaged him the underground monkey
i've never seen clown yeah but that was
pretty good yeah
i would love to watch a movie
where monkeys rip a clown apart make it
happen
uh so he go he goes to his boarding room
and he just stays in there
and the the stuart's out looking for him
in hamburg
um they finally have to like drag the
steward back on the ship they're like
you can't because he's like thinking
about just staying in hamburg
i'm gonna actually live here to kill him
kill him is that cool yeah i'm gonna
live here to kill him
and then after a few days he goes to the
harbor sneaks around to make sure the
ship's gone
it is and uh he starts walking backwards
the idea that he's like ah
dude yeah you're kind of a psychopath it
turns out so what's the deal
all right well that was a little
breather and unpaused because he had to
start from the dock
yes of course you get it you know he's
freeze he's made a lot of rules i've
made up rules for my magic walk
this person who's been following him has
also followed him to hamburg
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh he found out about the what happened
with the lie and all that because one of
the guys on the ship wrote him a letter
and the crew loved it
okay yeah good good last prank uh so
the germans were interested in the
walking backwards man
on the street they're all gathering
around how to weaponize him
it's crazy look at this could be a bomb
pretty soon a reporter starts asking
questions what's the deal why do you
do this why you walk backwards seems
very crazy and bad
american's insane yeah uh so he goes to
the american embassy
tells him what he's doing they're like
oh that's cool they give him two cartons
of cigarettes and wish him luck hey
that's pretty stupid here's some smokes
he goes he goes to the german police
station cause he's smoking everyone's
smokes yeah i think so just walking
backwards smoking
he yeah i know he goes to a or he sold
him maybe i don't know but i think he's
smoking i think everybody smokes i think
it's the law
that's just a crazy what do you want
camels marlboroughs
uh whatever my life's not really a life
anymore
so fun enough whatever you want
uh so he goes to german police station
because he just doesn't want any trouble
in right he wants to make sure yes he's
been
paraded he just he wants a clear walk
through germany and so
they have a little meeting they talk
about it and they go it's not safe we
don't like this idea
so he whips out his glasses and he
throws them on
and he walks around the station to the
front door zigzagging between
look at what he asks and like when he
gets to the door
the whole police station breaks into
applause
it's just not what you would it doesn't
feel real it doesn't feel german
no you have somehow formed our hearts
and changed our minds i feel alive
we didn't know that you were such an
adept
angler so that's it he's off
across church isaac
yeah so he's just walking across germany
now he's meeting people everyone's very
kind and they're helping him
there's not really hotels that it's not
really a thing so
he needs help from strangers
smelly backwards walking it just seems
like back then a lot of people let a lot
of other people stay in their house yeah
no these leave doors open it's crazy
yeah
so um so they're giving them food
they're letting them stay for the night
communication very hard right sure
yes well so he's usually using pantomime
or charades to communicate with people
that he needs a place
and then he's walking around the world
backwards
so me me me american
american okay yeah um yeah my wife yeah
not supportive oh yeah huge after yeah
finger off
yeah finger come off well the ring comes
up and then i'm walking
yeah the wrong way backwards oh okay
around the world you know the whole this
whole thing's the world yes
the whole thing's the world yes he's
walking in circles around the world
uh-huh
yeah and i'm walking backwards uh-huh
around i need to sleep
he's tired yeah i need to sleep here and
eat
don't knock down some of your jokes and
porridge food yes tell me your porridge
yes
in the bears yeah no bears sorry someone
said bears which is a
alarming the three oh goldilocks are the
three bears
sure yeah sure i need a porridge at
whatever temperature
because i'm going he's jogging
this way he likes to exercise and i have
one suit
i smell like [ __ ] he needs to go poop
no no no no i smell like i pooped he
needs to make boom boom i smell like i
made boom boom
because of my suit he wants to [ __ ] in
his shirt
no no no no no it smells like a [ __ ] in
my shirt i didn't
but it smells smelly he smells he's
awful
yes yes bad yes bad yes i like the smell
of his own actually i'm sorry i did [ __ ]
my pants i just realized i actually did
[ __ ] my pants i'm sorry i should i
i did [ __ ] he has medical problems i did
[ __ ] my prob
my pants unable to hold within himself
his [ __ ]
if sure i [ __ ] my pants just say [ __ ] my
pants you must be a thing here
yeah yeah okay so um do i live here for
a couple days
uh please go away okay well that's a lot
of energy i just expounded on my pitch
for you to just tell me to go away
yeah you were very positive when it came
to the porridge and stuff and now you're
now it's
i think france more often it's really
far i'm walking
backwards i'm not walking forwards i'm
not jogging i just seem very french
i'm no no why cause i'm smoking so much
it's just gross and you [ __ ]
yourself
i didn't what are you are your neighbors
cool
i'm going to every house okay uh
you're a real [ __ ] you know that
hello bye bye
hello oh god hello
[Laughter]
so in berlin he goes to the paramount
pictures corporation
because he had met a man in connecticut
who told him to look up his cousin
when he got to berlin and they filmed
another newsreel
wow that's crazy that that actually
worked yeah
um he goes to the american consulate
they stupid american tries dumb [ __ ]
they had a letter there from his mother
addressed to the man who walks backwards
well that'd be me
and and then when he left they gave him
two cartons of cigarettes and wished him
good luck good luck
i don't smoke you do now try
so winter comes and he's walking in the
snow oh my god
uh not great he also doesn't have he's
still got that [ __ ] suit he doesn't
have the right chords
he's got the shorts but he he doesn't
have like the right clothes for this at
all
so some some men in a pub ask him
what he's doing and then he tells him
and they give
him secondhand clothes for the winner
okay so at least he's got that he's
still walking through the snow backwards
which is
a [ __ ] nightmare well by the way it's
also what every parent told our parents
they did as a child
that's right one man actually did do it
yeah now i walk backwards
through the snow so he crosses into
czechoslovakia oh my god it's just cra i
cannot believe
that he is this i mean he walks through
america
yeah and now he's in check yeah it's
insane
it's insane
and he goes into this small village now
he still has the sign on his back but
now it's in german because
they made it for him i bet you it said
something like dumb [ __ ]
and the locals they see him and they are
[ __ ]
furious okay they start screaming at him
they're running up and spitting in front
of his feet in the dirt
some are holding others back because
they're trying to attack him
oh my god and he's like i'm gonna have
to fight my way out of this backwards
they hate backwards people yes and the
further he goes into the village the
more people coming out and then they
just a
mob is formed and they're starting
marching towards him
and then a cop comes out of nowhere and
he tells all the people to stop
and he takes plenty into like a small
tavern and sits him down
tries to talk to him realizes he speaks
english goes and gets a translator
and then he listens to his story and he
goes oh the villagers thought you were
german because you had a german sign on
your back
and they [ __ ] hate germans i hate
germans too
they were gonna beat the living [ __ ] out
of you they would not let me stay there
even when i pooped so and they're like
no you're
fine you're american you're good to go
oh okay so they don't kill them
wow ah so it is fun it is way funnier to
think that the czech people
are just living at a backwards walker
and going to kill him for that
so he goes onto prague and he meets a
rich guy there
who loves a story buys him a new suit
oh my god talk about needed in vienna
they write a story about him in romania
romania romania he's like oh my god it's
been a year i've been walking for a full
[ __ ] year
crowds of romanians are following him
around bucharest and
bulgaria a methodist minister
gets him a few days in a in the hospital
for free because he looks so sickly
because he's so
listen skinny things are not good when
someone's like you probably just need a
few days in a hospital
like you're not sick but someone's just
like go just take three days in the
hospital
just go to the icu for a few would you
honestly
he walks across greece he gets to the
turkish border oh my god
and they're not amused they arrest him
they throw him in jail
that i mean he's crazy that's [ __ ]
you can't just
literally throw a guy in jail for
walking backwards it's just like come on
a man who speaks english comes and asks
him what he's doing
and if he had enough money to get
through turkey could anyone send him
money from america
obviously they're trying to get money
right and after a few days they release
him
and he gets to istanbul and he realizes
they sent word ahead because right when
he gets there a bunch of cops come and
arrest him again right
so they now have a money-making scheme
yeah they take him to the
capital city murder jail sure yep
right that's pretty that's certainly
that's what
yep that doesn't sound like a marvel
name that's fine we're gonna take you to
murder jail
every morning then we'd take him to a
courtroom and he would pantomime to a
judge
and then be put back in his cell so okay
me
me not from here walk
backwards around the world me me
oh [ __ ] then one day he's in the jail
and he hears someone talking english and
he yells out and the guy comes over he's
an assistant american ambassador
and he goes i'll look into your
situation so
in the u.s the ap has now printed a
story about his imprisonment oh my god
imagine being like ex-wife like jesus
christ
uh it was headlined texas crab in jail
texas crab yeah this is like a backwards
yeah but crabs don't walk backwards
no so the american con
the american council the guy the
ambassador is just not interested in
helping plenty he
he thinks his walking backwards is just
[ __ ] dumb and pointless
and if he decides to do that he can find
his way out
planets doesn't know what the charges
are he doesn't know why he's in jail
and then he finally finds out through
this assistant ambassador
he doesn't have enough money to get
through turkey and
walking backwards is a public nuisance
so he's a public nuisance yeah
and he the guy goes you need a credible
person to sign for you and say you won't
do anything illegal and you'll be
honest and then you can walk
backwards so he begs the assistant
ambassador to do it
another ap story is printed this one had
a plenty quote if only
if they'd only let me go backwards it
wouldn't be so bad
but i get all tuckered out now when i
have to walk forward it uses
such different muscles wow he
has he's completely swapped his leg
muscles
yeah his leg muscles are completely
reversed he's like an astronaut
i mean he's probably got like he really
probably does have like hooves at this
point i guess i can't imagine what his
legs look i would love to know
what they i mean they must look like
that's probably they probably claws
that's why they called them the crap
yeah so the assistant
ambassador finally agrees to sign the
papers
but he still can't convince the turks to
give
plenty his passport back now this i
don't understand trapped in turkey
walking backwards
they're saying we want you to have money
to be we want you to have enough money
to be here but
we're keeping your passport so i don't
know what the [ __ ] deal is right
um plenty stops by
the ambassador to see if the embassy to
see if the main ambassador is there he's
not and as he's walking out
he meets his rich italian guy ar
cerrelte and
they they immediately become friends
they start talking they hit it off
and chiropracti has he's really rich and
he has a very fancy hotel room
and they go back there and he's like
look man if you want to stay here
like i know you're totally [ __ ] i
there's many rooms in this hotel room
and you know why would you pay money if
you don't have any so
he goes you can totally stay here and he
does
and they start hanging out and he's
taken he's taking plenty all around
istanbul paying for everything
does he does he walk backwards when he's
recreationally going
he is now but i can't say for sure but
based on what he said to the paper i
think he is
that's so that's nice that's good he's
completely
and the and he he's like can i pay for
some of this and the guy's like look i'm
rich it doesn't
like why it doesn't matter the money is
nothing any issue
so he goes back to the ambassador and to
try to get the ambassador get his
passport back and the ambassador is like
i don't like what you're doing
because i i can't i can't condone it
he's sure that if plenty walks
onward to persia that he's [ __ ] dead
he says quote there are places in these
countries where there are no roads at
all just
desert jungle mean people heathens wild
animals
snakes let him walk through the jungle
let him please walk through the jungle i
want to hear him
walking through like i wanted bodies i
want to see him figure out how to get
out of a puma attack
backwards to be fair the ambassador has
been all over the world and war is
happening in persia at the time
he's probably right on some level like a
dude walking through the jungle at the
very
least is going to get malaria that's
dangerous yeah
but that's it so his journey is
that's it end it he can't get he can't
get out of this okay
so the jury he's in turkey yeah okay and
so he finally accepts us he's like i
guess
i gotta go home and he's like i'll gonna
be a long walk back but i'll do it
here's what i'll do i'll go to new york
and then i'll somehow get to california
and then i'll walk backwards from
california to texas to wrap it up
okay so he tells his italian friend
and they spend more time partying all
around istanbul like he's just having a
great [ __ ] time sure
but plenty's a little bit suspicious
because
this guy's being really generous and
then when he's speaking to
business associates they would always
look at plenty and laugh
um because they're talking in turkish
and doesn't know what they're saying
and the ambassador's like look this
isn't normal for someone to be this
generous i would just
keep your eye out like there's something
off here oh boy
and then uh sorrelty is like hey
i will i'm going to france and my
business is up here i got to go to
france
i'll pay for your way there if you want
to go there and you can get back to
america from there it'll be easier
and then they get on the ship and he
brings two extra trunks and you guys
you're like can you tell people these
are your trunks
it'll just oh sure it'll save me money
sure yeah the guy who has tons of money
is not trying to save a couple of bucks
i've watched lock up abroad
to know where this is headed will you
just take these two cocaine i mean
extra bags bags of bags boxes
this is clothes it's a clothes box don't
open these full of
their clothes don't sniff it either
don't do anything don't lick it
so plenty's like something's off here
and he runs off the ship and tells the
ambassador what's going on
okay gets back on wait he runs and tells
the ambassador hey this
dude's giving me like cases yeah he's
like something shady i'm gonna and then
he goes back to keep up appearances
okay um so when they get to marsai
the cops are waiting but there's nothing
in the trunks the ambassador
thinks that the drugs were unloaded at a
stop in
naples okay plenty would later write
that he helped catch a drug dealer but
there's zero record of it the
the we gotta go with the ambassador's
version right which is
there was nothing there but something
had gone down right most
likely plenty tipped the guy off and got
money okay
right okay but then they watched plenty
when he was in france for three days and
he was staying in the worst places and
acted like he had no money
okay but so the french consulate gets
plenty of job on a steamship heading
back to the us and he arrives
in new york on june 15th 1932. okay
he never said so this guy is like hey
i'm going to california meets a guy
going to california driving in a ford
jesus i don't know how this [ __ ] happens
with him but
he meets the guy the guy's like hey i'll
take you to california sure are you cool
or crazy either let's do it you seem
normal you're just walking around the
world back four or five days at a car
with you
so you have to drive backwards
[ __ ] is that cool yeah thank you
so he agrees to split gas money and pay
for hotels now where did he get the
money to do that
[Music]
and then when he gets to california he
goes to the summer olympics and he's
watching the olympics sure um he's
probably like i can't believe they don't
have a backwards walking around the
world event
i'm sure they will at some point sure uh
whatever they can scam
so he starts walking backwards again and
in anaheim people surround him
at a gas station and a cop sees pulls up
tells everyone to get out of there
scatter now play's changed a little bit
and he's like
look it's not illegal to walk backwards
and i can talk to these people
there's nothing illegal going on here
and the crowd starts to boo the cop and
then shout at him
the cop gets his card he's had enough
yeah he's no longer
rolling over yeah he's someone has found
their courage yes
uh so then he walks through the [ __ ]
desert
backwards backwards it's 120 degrees in
the desert
it's august time to start pushing that
peanut yes
it's [ __ ] august he sleeps on the
side of the road or shitty hotels if he
can
in phoenix oh you know nice phoenix in
august i was just there in august let me
tell you a cop stops him in phoenix and
says it's against the lotto walk
backwards
he handcuffs him and takes him to the
joe arpaio
yes he was back he was a robber yeah
takes him to the station takes him
downstairs and then downstairs there's
an old friend
of plenty's waiting there's a police
chief and reporter ha ha it's a joke
okay hahaha good joke yeah it's great
because it's based on my trauma
but it keeps happening for the last 18
years you're in a turkish prison
just let you know it's not so funny
because i was put into turkish prison
so he gets to texas now he knows people
in every town he's in because he's
getting back home
and um he finally walks into abilene
people there on the streets are waiting
for him it's a big big
to do his brothers his family della
and his daughter stella dell is now a
nurse
vivian's a hostess in a restaurant so
they're doing okay
okay people like why did you do it
i don't know yeah i mean basically his
reasons changed and he just says
i wanted to see the world okay
sure and he also says fort worth has
given me a big wad of cash
the the postcard the commerce uh
but that's not true that was he was just
making that up no one was giving him
money
i think he just didn't want to see yeah
he didn't want to be like i came back
broke yeah this didn't work out at all
well i'm actually talking to a guy about
cutting off one of my legs so that's a
deal i'm looking to kind of just
thread the needle on so there's no money
the entire
trip took one year six months nine days
and he had four dollars well
he did see the worth it he did see the
world he met people in a way you don't
meet people right
i mean there was that yep sure so
afterwards his wife
yep but she probably sounds like he
wanted to a little bit like he
uh it seems like you don't go walking
backwards alone if you're like i love
you
yeah yeah so he moved to archer city and
he got a job as a cook
uh della then moved there and in the
late 30s they remarried
ah did you just do me one favor and
don't walk backwards across the world
again no
promises babes
[Laughter]
um they opened another cafe together but
then they divorced in 1943.
well i'm off in 1945 he got a job
at another cafe and fell in love with a
waitress
okay she was 18. oh jesus he's 51 jesus
god
oh you want to show a picture of her for
gareth um
he married juanita in 1946.
what i'm sorry is that the waitress yeah
and she's
wearing his crazy glasses which now that
i'm seeing
up close are even crazier than i thought
yeah and he's wearing
flashlight glasses yeah
okay and she's yep okay
all right that's sure what yeah
so they would move around the country
just working in hospitality for years
they were house parents at ucla at the
fraternity a fraternity ucla for a
couple years until a pledge choked on
raw liver during hazing and the frat was
shut down
well it's good that uh that's consistent
he would always for the rest of his life
tried to make money off of his walk
he carried his journal around and his
newspaper clippings with him all the
time and would show them off
he brought it up so much that it annoyed
everybody i
bet yeah it is people he knew he would
just always yeah that time i walked
around there
yeah yeah yeah we remember yeah we know
jesus christ you know what that reminds
me of
yeah you know guacamole reminds me [ __ ]
you know what guacamole reminds me of no
you really don't no when i walked around
the world backwards for 18 months all
right
just you see because yeah i saw some of
i saw avocados on my walk
backwards i got to let you go i can't
have you work here anymore because you
know
intolerable i was like go once when i
was walking around the world
don't do this and um i need this it was
gutting to end i had a lot of tough
spots there
della was upset the conversation ended i
needed to end
i know what it's like to feel like
things need to end because when i was
walking backwards around the world i was
like this has got to stop
okay but i didn't want to stop yesterday
i broke an old man's dentures
yeah if i don't look at you
or say anything would that be helpful
well if you're having trouble looking at
someone i'd recommend putting out a pair
of glasses with mirrors on the side i
did that actually when i was walking
around the world backwards for a good uh
couple years that's fair and it was a
way to sort of see behind you
i was very agreeable to my own thoughts
when i was walking around the world
backwards for a while
so i was sort of like doing what you do
when i'm like and i was kind of doing
that to myself
i need poison i need i felt like that
too this guy actually had this
all-in-one tonic that sort of reminded
me of poison the bottle looked like
poison i was
walking around the world backwards at
that time so that was that's that's very
interesting that you say that
that's that's obviously very connected
this guy had an all-in-one elixir
um and then i met a really rich guy and
um
and that was when i was walking around
the world backwards
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that's something i didn't
do a lot of when i was walking around
the world backwards i'll tell you that
my calves were [ __ ] though but uh no
della left me
but that was when i was walking around
the world backwards which i did do
uh not the whole world um because
eventually i got some
places and they i mean i was looking at
a backwards walk through the jungle and
they told me that you know those monkeys
will just rip me apart like a clown
so um i was like can't do that are you
laughing
yeah i didn't do a lot of laughing when
i was walking around the world backwards
because
there wasn't a lot of light thoughts in
my head
i'm so tired so you know what made me
really tired
he worked on the book for um
30 years he finally finished you got to
get it right in 1966 1966 it's full of
mistakes it has tons of photos well he
only had 30 years
one chapter was quote i startled the
mule
that's a good one that's how you know
those days were filled with a lot of
entertaining stuff
you know which chapter we could probably
lose is the one where you startled the
mule
so no one buys it interesting
uh he was in ripley's believe it or not
and the guinness book of world records
for the longest backwards walk
eight thousand miles still is crazy
johnny carson had him on the tonight
show in july 1976. he's 81 years old
that was to promote a backwards walk he
was doing from la to san francisco
400 miles at 81 years old and he did it
because he was getting 500
from ripley's believe it or not where
the walk would end oh my god
he also got 370 from the tonight show
that hall was the most he ever made from
the walk
one of his sisters died in 1988 and when
the funeral was over he set up a card
table
to sell his books in the church
[Laughter]
now you know why he didn't get a sponsor
right oh he didn't get a sponsor because
he was
crazy and annoying
in 1980 okay that's hard you know we all
grieve in different ways
i actually wrote a book um have you ever
startled a mule you're going to love
chapter 19.
oh and i have googly eyes if you have to
buy those
i'll miss her but um at least i have
these things
you know the book then and at least i
have a two for once so yeah
yeah so it's just it's uh six bucks each
or it's two for ten
in 1991 he was living in wichita falls
yeah he had medical bills uh so he
called the reporter and said he said he
was willing to sell the rights to his
feet after he died the story was in all
the papers in the u.s no one took his
offer
he arrived at home on august 2nd 1993.
wow how old was he what
and then uh jesus 90s he's in his 90s
yeah
wow is he in his 90s 86 70s 605
no he born in 2000 yeah it was almost
100.
wow late 90s this most of this uh all of
it was just from
the book uh the man who walked backward
by ben montgomery
wow it's a great great history book what
a great
little story isn't that crazy that's
crazy
it's it's crazy that i mean i guess it
makes sense you've never heard of him in
a way because it's like he didn't really
do too much
but i you know you talk about
hearing things on this show where you're
like this is exciting hearing the
thesis statement of a man is going to
walk backwards
is exciting around the world i mean
what the [ __ ] happens in people's brains
you know we all process trauma in our
own ways and
i mean is this [ __ ] it's none of this
[ __ ] the
flagpole sitting which was a big thing
people would sit at flag poles for days
none of this is different than the [ __ ]
you see on youtube or people just
desperately trying
none of it it actually reminds me of
david blaine like it's like
that level of because it isn't a way
mind over matter [ __ ]
it's like that is a crazy thing to do to
walk
that far you really i mean obviously at
times you're thinking about stopping or
getting depressed about it i mean just
imagine how i mean he
he must have been in so much pain i
would think you would be in so much pain
i mean i just can't imagine swapping
your calf muscles to the front of your
leg
no it must be very strange oh it's got
to be insane
and the fact that why not yeah your
all your hamstrings everything would be
all out of whack yeah you think for
years
he would be on rogan oh yeah he would be
on rugged for sure
i i just i don't know i'm like i do
i it is it's hard to get a profile of
this man's
mental state it's not great it can't be
great
there there's also i think for me it
just seems like
it's a desperate desire for fame that's
all i wanted it was just famous
that was it that's true he didn't want
anything else he didn't know about his
family youtube is a good comparison
yeah you know it's like he's he's just
he's trying to go viral yeah yeah he was
trying to go leg viral
and i'm sure the selling of the books of
the funeral that's just to get people to
see why i don't think that's what he's
i don't know i know that seems i i i
remember when my grandmother died i was
selling cds well yeah i mean the funeral
parlor that
uh that we took my dad to they have a
merch area yeah they get like 25
well that's my favorite thing to ask
anyone who's officiating some sort of
funeral what's the merch situation do i
do merch before or after
i feel like get them on the way in so
they're not sad is that crazy
you know what i'll do i'll set it up and
i'll do it before and after now uh we
got we got the
we have the urn and we have um we have
the date all set up okay
do you would you like us to make shirts
would you like um we could make hats
i think hats and koozies yeah for sure
people love well they're cheap to make
and um
and people love them and they're tasty
we can make them it's easy to pack and
stuff
they don't need to be tasteful we can do
like a goodbye gams we can do uh
uh i would maybe lean i would maybe go
more in the direction of like
you know we're all grieving but only one
of us has felt that walking around the
world backwards
you know i looked it my way i built it
my way i love that yeah um
i think that's the way to go yeah and
then we also have fake turds
that's great that's great to hear yeah
yeah i'm going to definitely want those
on the merch table and i'm thinking
while we
cremate maybe i'm walking backwards
along the stage
putting out the candles or something
sure we can do that whatever it is
yeah maybe i'll walk around the coffin a
couple times backwards when
you and i also think what would be cool
if you're down
maybe we bury her and then exhume it
sort of like a backwards funeral
just to replay into the whole theme of
my life and career
yeah we can sell a shirt if we're coming
back up out that's great
that's great that's great uh my heart's
in the right place i love what you guys
are doing here this is this is going to
be awesome
i'm really excited for my system let's
do this let's [ __ ] do this yeah
well normal stuff dave normal stuff
normal stuff as usual
we do we did it again we did it again
right cavs
you